and minimalists ladies and gentlemen
Canyon City welcome everybody
so first of all you are too minimalist
show don't worry but these guys are so
they're just being so kind and letting
me tag along on this tour and play a
couple songs to start things off so
you're in for a wonderful night some
really meaningful conversations I'm real
excited personally so I hope you all
enjoy it as much as I know I will but
I'm go ahead and dive into it this is a
song of mine called train
[Music]
let me die city sirens
under the lights with a liar's glow
we're in life life uncut diamonds
learning the lines for the evening show
[Music]
I wanna lie down southern Georgia
[Music]
I wanna call dogs by name
[Music]
you the one with Carolina
[Music]
put on a write good on e fire and rain
put on a record on even me the pain you
never know what to you hear the train so
now I live in on tomorrow's rain
tonight all of you to slip away
it's not all of it is
give me some work on your heartbreak
driver
[Music]
me summer hurt I'll come pick you up
[Music]
I wanna learn lift you higher
[Music]
I get so low honey use me as a rock
I get solo honeybee the try
you never know I keep to this stop so
now I live it on tomorrow's bro peacocks
[Music]
yah
tonight I love you to you
yeah
[Music]
I think I'll die with these miles
between us I'm good to drive just make
some space this picture I got won't do
justice
the way your eyes never really find my
face the key now I'm on my way
you know come here when you
that train tonight we live it on
tomorrow straight hours
- those pictures hey tonight I love you
- the colors change it's not all of UT's
[Music]
thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
well as you already know you're here to
see the minimalists some of my so uh in
spirit of that this is a song that you
may recognize here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anybody know what it is
there's some good advice in here I wish
I wrote it I didn't it's a man named
Peter drew
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing you think that
you need every little thing that's just
feeding you Creed or bet that you'd be
fine without it
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little things you gotta all the
Cherise full and all that you grab or a
bet that you'd be fine without it
[Music]
so tears way oh dear
[Music]
every little thing sparkles and shines
every little thing that sparkles and
shines it's driving you sweet I do mind
but I bet that you'd be fine without it
so tears way
but yeah
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the minimalist
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Canyon City ladies and gentlemen man do
we have a special night planned for
tonight oh it has been for almost five
years since we've been back here in
Kentucky and it's so good to be back so
so you know it's it's like a blast from
the past today my my brother's here
tonight my sister here is here tonight
you know and you know they come down
from Ohio so we grew up you go right up
71 a little bit we're right up right up
the road the same humidity just you know
across the mason-dixon line and and then
tonight we were doing this little
pre-show Meetup Q&A upstairs and like
I'm given this impassioned talk and I
feel like I'm doing really well and I
turn around and I see my boss the first
person who ever hired me brought me into
Telecom and all of a sudden I froze like
am i late for a meeting or something
but it's it's so great to see like and
we were actually talking he brought some
pictures of me when I was 18 it was
before I realized I had hair so I had a
shaved head and I was wearing a suit
that was too large for me and I had
maybe 60 pounds more on my body then and
I as I was going through these mixes of
emotions in my head what I realized just
just seeing Jeff there was like man I
couldn't be doing this right now if it
weren't for everything that went wrong
and everything that went right leading
up to this moment like when I when I
first embraced the corporate world when
I was 18 and then you came along a few
years later I cuz misery loves company
I am I
I was so introverted and I'm still
really really introverted but I was
forced to actually deal with people
instead of just hiding behind a computer
screen or whatever and I think it made
me a better person getting myself into
a discomfort zone in the backstage we
were just talking about like there are
three things that I hate public speaking
crowds of people and travel and here we
are and I do this for a living and and
what I realized is I don't actually hate
those things right they make me
extremely uncomfortable but that place
of discomfort is the place from which I
grow so I hope that you get something
out of this tonight because I know that
it helps me grow it helps me shape the
person I'm going to be in the future and
I know we're really grateful you decided
to be here tonight so what do you say we
record a podcast this evening beautiful
I say we do it Ryan let's do it all
right well live from Louisville my name
is Joshua fields Milburn welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less and your Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are the minimalist and we
are live in Louisville
[Applause]
man Birmingham's would be really jealous
when they hear that that was way more
excitement we do have a special guest
with us here tonight we set out to do
this you know last year we did a 50 city
tour and we wanted to do something more
manageable this year so we're on a three
city tour and it's the the simply
southern tour of Birmingham a couple
nights ago and now we're here in in
Louisville and we wanted to talk about
money and minimalism we wanted to do
something a little bit different this
time around and so instead of Ryan and I
just getting up here and like talking
about our checking accounts or something
they'd get really boring if like Ryan
showed you how to balance your checkbook
this evening god that's about all I can
do when it comes to finances like I
really wish I was the finance guy like
you know if you if you had some money to
invest I wish people would be like you
know what you need to talk to Ryan
Nicodemus he knows exactly what you
should I haven't know I mean I just do
what what experts like we're about to
bring on tell me to do and it's so
important to have experts like this in
our lives yes indeed so without further
ado let's welcome to the stage you
probably know him as the author of
retire inspired he has a podcast by the
same name he has a new book coming out
really soon as well we're gonna talk
about that a little bit it's called
everyday millionaires and I think you'll
actually be surprised by some of the
things he has to talk about with respect
to money ladies and gentlemen please
welcome to the stage Chris Hogan
[Applause]
now is it true that you were the wizard
in The Wizard of Oz never so I mean
because his voice is is his voice I
think we'll just shut up for most of the
evening
but we do have we do have a couple
microphones here we're gonna have a
brief conversation but we're really here
for you all so we have a microphone here
and a microphone here there's a
difference between these two microphones
this one if you have questions about
money so maybe if you have questions
about debt or budgeting or retirement or
savings or investing that's this
microphone over here on your right my
left and then this microphone over here
if you have a question about minimalism
or letting go no at this one over here
or Josh's hair right there yeah yeah
whatever you have a question about
miscellaneous questions for any of us
then this is the microphone to do that
so feel free to to come on up we can
form a line on on the sides and before
we get to those questions as you all
line up I just want to talk to Chris
first of all thank you for being here
and in your book you you have your most
recent for your first book I should say
retire inspired you you talked about
some of the common mistakes and myths
when we think about retirement what
compelled you to start writing about
about the topic of retirement yeah thank
you for the question you know the big
thing for me was coaching people I was
sitting with people everyday people
kneecap to kneecap helping them with
their money I've been a part of Dave
Ramsey's team for thirteen years now and
you know really talking to people
everyone was making some assumptions
every people were thinking that Social
Security was going to be enough to save
the day they thought that that would
they didn't have to worry about doing
anything that Social Security would take
care of them and then I would hear
people saying well when I get to age 65
or when I get to 70 and I kept looking
and I kept hearing these myths over and
over again and then I psych someone's
got to do something like someone needs
to tell people that retirements not an
age it's a financial number someone
needs to tell people that Social
Security won't be enough for you to live
your dream and so I kept saying this
over and over and then I
you know curling my hair one day right
haha I was shamed people don't laugh I'm
bald by choice I can grow all the hair I
want in this section right here but
anyway but I kept thinking someone needs
to do something I realized you know what
I needed to be that somebody I wanted to
try to help yeah so what were some of
those myths that you came across I mean
we often think that like there was two
things that I encountered I used to
manage a large group of people at one
point I was a director of operations for
150 retail stores and one of the things
I know that I did right because I did a
lot of things wrong is I started saving
for retirement early now I didn't start
saving enough but I started saving
earlier just kicking some money into a
401k and I helped other people sign up
for those 401k accounts as soon as they
were on-boarded with with our company
and in in doing that I saw a couple
excuses one excuse was I'm too old to
start saving for retirement which sounds
crazy to me and the other excuse which
was even crazier was I'm too young I'll
get to that someday where those some of
the excuses that you came across those
are two of the biggest one that that I
would hear people would think it was too
late for them because they didn't get
started early and so baby boomers are on
down the line and I kept explained to
them no no you still have an opportunity
to do something you've got an
opportunity to make new decisions today
that will impact your dreams and young
people telling them you know they say
well Chris you know at retirement says
for old people and I'd say it's not an
age it's a financial number so getting
them to understand your money has two
best friends time and compound interests
if your money gets to sit there on a
401k or 403b
with time and compound interest that
money will earn more money down the road
so if I can get young people started
right and get people that are a little
bit older to realize it's not too late
what you have is people are still able
to chase their dreams
people are still able to have options
for themselves and that's what I want
ultimately I want people doing the
things they want to do not waking up to
wake work another 12 to 14 hour shift on
the job they don't love and now with
this with this new book that you have
coming out
people we have this weird misconception
about the term millionaire I'm
personally not a millionaire I hope to
be one day and and but getting there
doesn't mean you're making a million
dollars a year what are some of these
misconceptions and you you've done the
largest study now of millionaires across
the country and you realize that Oh most
millionaires are just normal people who
made some really good decisions with
their money year after year after year
no you're right I mean and that's why
we're titled the book every day
millionaires because it's everyday
people it's not someone that's making a
million dollars a year this is someone
that has a net worth so we're talking
net worth millionaires so when you look
at your assets minus your liabilities at
the end you have a net worth of a
million or more and that can happen with
you paying off your home that can happen
with you having a 401k or 403b so it's
the culmination of a lot of work but
their myths surrounding it people think
well I've got to make a million dollar
income no you don't we've even found in
our research that you don't even have to
make a six-figure income it's a matter
of having a plan being intentional so
again I'm going back to coach people to
help them to understand it's available
like the American Dream is still alive
and it's available we just have to move
in the right direction and use the right
tools yeah you are a great coach man
what I really appreciate about a retired
inspired is how you kept coming back to
these football references I mean I
Josh's basketball fan I'm a huge
football fan so I I really I really
caught on to those but you know my whole
my whole life I've heard people say you
know life is a game and treated as a
game and and I think I looked at that in
the competitive sense and after it and I
kind of like just shoot that advice away
like I'm not gonna treat life like a
game I'm not gonna try and be better
than people but when you started using
those football references what I realize
is that you can treat life you could
treat your own life as if it is a bit of
a game meaning when I think about what
it takes to be a good football player
well you've got to get to practice
sometimes you got to do two days you got
to eat right you got it there are all
these little things you can do to be a
really really excellent football player
it's the same thing with our finances
there are all these small things and big
things we can do to be great at our
finances and I think
the biggest thing one of the biggest
misconceptions that people have is is
when it comes to the stock market in
fact my little sister sorry I'm calling
you out here Olivia earlier today she
was late she out but what was telling
her about you and I'm like oh man you're
gonna because she's 22 years old I'm
like man you're gonna love Chris he's
got great advices he's gonna help you
retire she's like you know I've already
I've already started saving $15 out of
my paycheck each week and it goes right
into a savings account and I'm like
that's great that is an awesome start
but can you tell her in anyone else why
why a savings account may not be the
best place to park your money for
retirement and why maybe you should
invest in a net and an index fund for
example okay so I love the fact that
she's saving that is a great thing a
great job but what we want to do is we
want that money to grow it's just like
if we put a pizza oven and we turn twe
we don't turn the oven on it's not gonna
cook we got to get the oven preheated
and get it going and so I would say take
that money and let's move it into
something that's going to grow for you
right now when you said stock market I
heard some people go
you know because if we don't understand
it we don't like using it right so I
want to help people look at the stock
market totally different I want you to
think of a supermarket right you go to a
supermarket there are all kinds of
things there you can buy there are
things that are good for you and there
are things that are not so good for you
right and so you think about that I want
you to look at the stock market the same
way as you with the supermarket the
stock market has things that you can
invest them that are good for you but it
also has some things that are not so
good it turns out it's all based on our
risk tolerance like watch this tonight
skies kind of mess with the audience for
minutes all right you all says ok here
we go
raise your hand if you always drive the
speed limit okay there are two hands up
okay - we got a whole lot of people in
this room there's two hands up raise
your hand if you drive five miles over
the speed limit okay all right
okay all right raise your hand if you
drive 10 miles over the speed limit okay
now this one's the one raise your hand
if you drive I don't want to know how
many miles of the speed limit
okay all right come on in police we got
them I asked that because it's just like
the way we drive we also can invest the
same way it's based on how much risk
we're willing to take people that only
drive five miles over the speed limit no
there's a lower probability they'll get
a ticket ten miles over it depends on
where you are right if you're on the
interstate you could be okay if you're
on a side street you gonna have a
problem right those that are driving I
don't want to know how many miles of
this B limit you just need to envelope
ready right just go home and get ready
to pay that ticket people invest the
same way and because we're wired and
designed differently there are things
out there for you to invest in based on
the way that you're wired and so I want
people to understand you know the stock
market is a good thing it can help us
when you're investing the right way
before we dive into some of these
questions here we hear this term all the
time and it drives me insane
well first off sometimes we hear
politicians refer to millionaires and
billionaires as if that were the same
thing and it's like saying thousand airs
and millionaires it's the same
discrepancy right why why is this term
millionaire so
with ties these days as if like a person
is evil because they've worked really
hard all of their life to achieve this
certain level of comfort or wealth or
the ability to give to other people and
and I think maybe we don't understand
that like what you can also do with
wealth is is part of what I mean yeah
you can buy nice things if you want to
buy that in Ryan and I are we're
minimalist but we're not against owning
things you know we're in closed right
now we we drove a car here you know like
we owned stuff we just don't have excess
stuff but the money that we do make
we're able to use that to invest in
other people or to invest in charity as
well can you talk about the stigma
behind this millionaire mindset yeah a
lot of people they do they make some
assumptions about millionaires that they
had to cheat to be able to get their
money that they inherited their money
right that's the way they got their or
they had to go to an Ivy League school
or they had some luck in the way that
they got there and the reality is is
that everyday people are doing it the
everyday way where they're getting
themselves out of debt they're investing
they're allowing time and compound
interest to grow their money they're
staying focus right they're not allowing
their wants to get in the way of their
needs or if they do they do it with cash
so there are a lot of stigmas out there
but I really appreciate you hitting on
to me the most important thing there are
a lot of charities out there that I
believe in there are a lot of things out
there people that I want to help our
veterans people like that single moms
I'm the product of a single parent so my
heart goes out to a lot of those areas
but in order to be able to help I have
to have the ability and this is gonna
sound weird but I want you to hear the
heart behind it broke people can't help
other people and so if there is some
kids you want to help to feed if there
are some charities that you believe in
because you know what they stand for
I've been the father of a special-needs
boy my youngest son and he's had some
serious medical issues and we've met
other families that are walking through
tough situations but in order for him to
be able to help people I have to be in a
position to do that and I'm talking
monetarily we also have to be in a
position to be able to help with our
in our talent those are other ways that
we're able to give and so what we have
to do is make some decisions we've got
to take a stand for some things and then
really start to go down that path you
know it's interesting as everyone here
tonight I mean you all Fabozzi who know
about me and Ryan I don't haven't even
ever seen us live before Wow well
welcome to our cult
lock the doors podcast on wait a minute
I'm gonna call I have news for you Ryan
you're leading the cult that's how it
always works no um right Ryan and I are
debt free we've been debt free but
here's the thing like we were in the
corporate world I made really good money
thank you I made really good money in
the corporate world but I spent even
better money and so there was a point at
the sort of apex where I made a couple
hundred thousand dollars a year but of
course I had the big suburban house with
more toilets than people I didn't
actually own the house I just you know I
paid the bank on this 30-year mortgage
that I had I had the closets full of
designer clothes I had the luxury cars
plural I had more than one Lexus I don't
know what the plural for Lexus is pretty
sure it's LexA okay and and so I had all
I had accumulated all of these things
that make me look rich I was broke man
and it got to a point where I wasn't
just broke I was broke in because I
realized like the person I wanted to
become the person who was contributing
to a community the person who was
helping other people the person who was
living a life that aligned with his
values I wasn't that person in fact I
was getting farther away from that
person because I was spending money I
didn't have on things I didn't need to
impress people I didn't even know and in
doing that I realized I needed to to
make a change and it meant simplifying
my life and make making some sacrifices
in my life
it meant delivering pizzas for a while
to pay off some debt even though I was
in the corporate world
it meant doing some things that I was
not comfortable with doing so that I
could eventually live the life I wanted
to lead and now that you would go on
tour and you all paid money to get in
here tonight and if I wasn't debt free
if I didn't have that foundation that I
couldn't say this next thing is a
hundred percent of the profits from this
tour are going to build a grocery store
in West Dayton we're from yeah thank you
thank you
so we're from around the street Dayton
Ohio
it's the overdose capital of America and
the west side doesn't have a single
grocery store there's a million people
in the metro area a couple hundred
thousand people in the city the entire
west side of the city is a food desert a
second hungry City for families with
children and ever since 2008 they have
not had a grocery store on the west side
and we're trying to help change that but
if I had massive amounts of debt I mean
the thing I would have to do right now
is well you all paid some money and so
I'm gonna go pay off that debt and that
would be completely acceptable but now
that I'm debt-free
I have some options that I can do with
that money
I love the word options I do I really do
because no one wants to be limited it we
all want options we want choices we want
to make some decisions about things for
ourselves we want decisions and options
for our food for the things that we
drink how about for your dreams we want
we need to have those options as well I
was in your camp I'm a former banker my
income would rise each year but guess
what so would my stupidity
no I'm serious you all I would do it I
would just have a psyche all right you
know what I'm gonna get serious when I
make more money and I'd make money and I
got more serious I got so mad I got my
my w-2 one year right and I look at it I
go this amount of money came through my
hands and I was like where did it go
I got mad or when I got my car I was
like I'm gonna go find my money no see I
was so irritated right and I drove by
the mall and I was like well someone in
there and there's a sporting goods store
and restaurants and I realize I took my
money and I made it there money because
I had a problem I didn't have limits I
didn't understand my goals I'm a hard
worker but at some point
you have to realize your hard work alone
won't get you there you need a plan that
actually will work and so it's so
important for us to have that awareness
but then to make those adjustments you
know debt is a thief it steals it steals
from you now and it steals from you
later if you start to think about that
and so I want more people to have more
of their dreams that they're living I
don't want you to go work for a Visa or
Discover or American Express or any of
those other people because here was my
wake-up call
if something happened to one of my
children Visa American Express and all
the rest of them none of them would care
enough about me to come to help me
they take that's a one-sided
relationship so that's not a good thing
so I had that wake-up call and a
perspective change for myself so much so
I sacrificed the motorcycle I'm so glad
you brought that up man
so so tell them about how sometimes
there are things in our life that we
really want and we want this other thing
also but it doesn't always work out that
way no it really doesn't I think we set
ourselves up for frustration and
irritation when we try to accomplish too
much when you try to keep doing what
you're doing and get better
it slows things were you look and you go
wait a minute I'm driving myself crazy
I'm stealing my own joy I need to
understand I've got to stop something so
I can start doing some things that are
better for me as well as my family and
so I was showing pictures to my boys I
have three sons I have a 14 year old a
12 year old an 11 year old and they're
why I have this gray hair in my beard
but I was showing them pictures my two
youngest I showed them pictures of
motorcycles they they didn't believe
that I had one they think daddy was just
you know they think I'm old right I
can't be cool why didn't have a
motorcycle so I was showing him I go no
guys this is the one and they said well
what happened I said well I made your
mother a promise that when we had our
first child that's Tyson that I'd sell
the motorcycle so ty comes in ten
minutes later he goes what are you all
doing now my middle boys wired like his
daddy so he's kind of direct right and
so Brock says we're looking at the
motorcycle dad used to have and I say
well why don't you have anymore Brock
said you you are the cause right and I
was like that's true that is
and then I had to let him know no I
explained to him I made a sacrifice I
sold it so I could attack those last two
credit cards I made a sacrifice I made a
choice and it was one of those things
where was a grow up moment for me to
realize I know hard work pays off right
but a house will have to be thinking
forward and I've got to understand what
am I willing to stop so I can start some
things but what am I willing to give up
so I can gain some better things
absolutely I think sometimes we have to
untether from that past and that means
sometimes untethering temporarily from
the good things and it's it's a
temporary deprivation what you're not
talking about is you need to deprive
yourself for the rest of your life from
any sort of pleasure means hey maybe
maybe I've been spending money that what
hasn't been mine all along and I need to
fix that if I want to actually get
control of this thing called finances
yeah so so when we have questions
tonight I mean I don't see anyone lined
up yet so here's what happens it's gonna
be the shortest podcast ever you're all
gonna have wasted your money now someone
has to break the seal that's how this
works tonight I mean not literally
hopefully but come on up to the mic and
we've got some questions here and and I
know Chris has some answers
howdy what's your name my name is Mugsy
Mugsy where you from thank you love you
too I love the word y'all honestly I
could have spoken on either microphone
because my question is kind of combines
minimalism and my retirement dream and
so here's here's the deal so Chris I had
my dream date with my husband when I was
in my 30s and and we kept that going in
our 40s and in our 50s but now I'm
closer to 60 and I find myself I'm
divorced after 31 years and so I'm all
alone
so my dream date and my dream for
retirement kind of changed a little bit
so here's my here's my dilemma so I'm a
minimalist and my my kiddos are too I
have two adult children one who's close
to your guys's age and my daughter who's
here who's in her late 20s and they
really you know they know mom is like
really happy and everything is good with
minimalism so here's my two options so
originally I we were going to retire in
2020 I could retire in in October of
2020 which you know is not that far away
and I'm a minimalist and based on my
budget I could retire and be good but
Chris I want to leave a legacy and I
wanna I want to build up my nest egg and
and my kids are like mom oh you know we
don't need your money you know blah blah
blah and so I just want your feedback on
my two options you know I could go out
early but but my why like when I wake up
in the morning is them yes Wow
first of all congratulations on you
putting yourself in a position I'm proud
of you okay the way you were just
speaking with passion if you live
halfway as passionate as you were just
talking I already know what you've
deposited in your children legacy is not
just about money it's the way we live
it's how we love people and see them so
I know you've made deposits there I
think what your kids are telling you as
mama you've raised us well enough we
don't need your money we don't need a
set dollar amount they love you enough
that they want to see you happy and so I
think what you have to do is really
start to make some decisions and really
step back
can look at your legacy that what
they're already doing and how they're
living and I think you've got to do
something that a lot of people struggle
with is you've got to start to put you
first you've sacrificed you've done some
stuff now let's get back to your dream
what makes you happy and really look at
your options and make some decisions
if 2020 is the time that you can do that
you start to think about what's next for
you what are you gonna do we fear the
unknown so having a plan for that cuz
it's easy to keep working because that's
what we know but now you start to look
and think what do I want to do where the
places I want to travel what are the the
mission trips I want to take the family
I want to go see thinking about those
things now it'll demystify that new
shift for you and you were able to move
forward how are we supposed to follow
that before before the podcast Ryan's
like why do you keep bringing these
smart people on it's like you realize it
makes us look bad right let me tell you
just a quick story when I was I was
three years old living on Green Street
in Dayton Ohio and I'm neighbor asked me
what do you want to do when you grow up
right essentially what is your dream
right I was three and so I said I want
to be a ninja or an alligator so we did
both I think the lesson from that story
is that sometimes our dreams change over
time right and we're able to reframe
those dreams I didn't accomplish either
one of those but it has shifted quite a
few times since then sometimes it's a
radical change sometimes it's a pivot in
just five degrees one way but guess what
happens when you pivot five degrees that
dream change is just a little bit
because for you legacy may it may have
meant one thing but legacy doesn't look
like Chris it legacy doesn't just mean
I'm gonna leave some money for my kids
that's not a legacy that's a trust-fund
legacy means I instilled some values in
my children i invested in them and
ways and I'm leaving a legacy by the way
there's other ways to leave a legacy not
with just your children or your loved
ones but with your community and and and
I can tell you that one of the things
that I've been freed up to do now is
invest in a community and invest in
other people and I think your dream is
gonna pivot five degrees but a year from
now that five degrees is gonna put you
in a different destination two years
from now five years from now you're
gonna be a completely different place
because legacy is gonna mean something
different to you
yeah and I want to talk about something
that that Chris helped me to to kind of
push out the age that I wanted to retire
I mean I didn't really have a set age
you know I just always assumed like yes
I will one day have enough money to
retire and when that age hits like
that's when I will retire maybe I'll be
55 maybe I'll be 65 but Chris talks a
lot about free money and when when I
think about retired inspired and about
the how social security works so what
age is that you can start collecting
Social Security 100 percent of its it's
65 65
yes 65 years old so you're not gonna be
65 in in 2020 but if you waited until
you were 65 you you could collect 100
percent of that and then what happens it
no you wait til 70 it goes up to a
hundred and twenty percent that sounds
like free money to me right it is it's a
it's a great option but you know I want
to go back to the whole the decision my
grandparents did not leave me a lot of
money but those were two of the the best
people I've known on this planet and we
spent a lot of time we hung out and the
legacy they left inside of me is the way
that I view people how I care about them
and how I just I want to help as many
people as possible so your legacy is
bigger yeah it's okay to leave them some
money but more importantly it's what
you've said the values the way they see
you the way you've treated them the way
they treat others so it's big so I think
you've got a lot of opportunity ahead of
you and I want you to grab it with both
hands and live life to the fullest
Thanks your question thank you
you know real quick she mentioned
something that I just want to encourage
people to do she mentioned the dream
date
I encourage me if you're married to sit
down together and talk about your ideas
for the future what do you want for the
kids what do you want for each other
because we don't talk about our dreams
we get so busy living life day-to-day
that we forget and our dreams can
motivate us so I don't care if you're
single newly single or married thinking
about the things you'd love to do in the
future if it's mission trips spending
time with family travel whatever that is
I want people to start to tap into that
because that will motivate us to start
to take the steps we need to for our
future it's gonna help you get there
because you're gonna get on the same
page and if you're on the same page
you're gonna start if you travel in
different directions you never get to
the same destination
howdy what's your name where you from
Hamburg
born and raised in Louisville my
question is uh I'm doing okay I'm 28 and
I've got to finally get a job that's
going somewhere I've got a 400 K 401k
with the company and you know I'm doing
okay right now but I'm also in that
stage run trying to jettison myself into
the next stage of life you know marriage
kids house stuff like that and I'm
wondering what's the best way to juggle
trying to get myself to the next stage
as well as saving for retirement and
also how you know whether you're whether
or not you're secure enough to
financially to go into the next stage
okay thank you for that question you
know too often times we try to do too
many things at once and we end up
getting frustrated right how many of you
remember the Atkins diet you remember
that you can eat a side of beef but you
couldn't have one potato chip right now
I was on that diet for about hold on
about two and a half hours and lost my
mind right I did I grabbed a bag of
Doritos and just demolished them right
because I was trying to do stuff so my
answer to you is this instead of trying
to do nine things at once I want us to
do one step at a time
that's why I talk about Dave Ramsey's
baby steps and so where that's where
again real quick
step number one you save $1,000 you get
that in place why because then you can
stop using debt for later maybe step two
is the big boy this is where you're
gonna list out your debts smallest the
biggest and I want you to attack the
little one first right cuz getting out
of debt in about math it's about
momentum so once you pay off that debt
and it can take 18 to 24 months once you
attack that but once you get that done
now I want you to move to baby step 3
which is save up a three to six months
emergency fund this is going to give you
a cushion in your life so if you have
job loss sickness or whatever you know
you've got money sitting there once you
do that then I encourage people to start
to invest right so baby step four is
investing fifteen percent of your
household income baby step five is
starting to save for college baby step
six is attacking and paying off the
house and baby step seven is build
wealth and give and so I'm giving you
this roadmap this is the thing we've
helped millions of families walk through
so instead of trying to do everything
I'd love for you to follow that linear
path so now you can start to gauge where
you are and what's next yes sir yeah a
great question I think the biggest part
to this formula to that you have laid
out is budgeting Josh and I we just we
were meeting with Anthony O'Neal we're
here with Chris we're gonna be with
Rachel Cruz in a couple days and I've
been reading all these financial books
and there's one common thing I see in
every single book is you have to have a
strict budget if you want to feel safe
with where your money's going do you
have a budget right now not at all okay
that's okay that's alright
but but start with that budget because
then you can start to allocate those
dollars every month if you want to save
for a house if you want to save for a
wedding to to well before you start
saving for a house or wedding pay off
those debts like Chris said but but that
budget is such a powerful tool III
budgeted to get debt-free and then as
soon as I became debt-free
I gotta admit man like the budget kind
of fell by the wayside like I really
just was like you know what I don't have
any more debts I don't have to be that
strict with it then I moved to Los
Angeles
thanks Chris and you know after living
there for almost a year
talking to Mariah I'm like we gotta get
and after reading these books I'm like
we have to get back on a budget like
this this is really important for us and
the reason why I'm saying that is
because my experience with the budget
just over the last couple months that
we've been we've been using it it has
dramatically changed my spending habits
to the point where if I'm you know on my
way walking to work and I want to you
know stop at the corner store and grab a
sparkling water or something it's you
know just my old attitude was it's just
three bucks I'm just gonna go on there
I'm gonna put it you know put three
dollars down grab my water and get out
of there well now I've got to go in
there I've got to take that three
dollars that I've already allocated to
something I got to spend it then I got
to go into my every dollar app and I got
it and I got to enter in that three
dollars that I spent and by the time I
go through that process in my head I'm
like and I'll just get some water when I
get to work I'll just drink some soft
water this is way too big of a pain in
the butt yeah well let me ask you this
what do you want security more than
anything else yeah I I think I think all
of us want security I think it's a I
think it's a human need why do you want
it there's too many unknowns out there
and I'd rather control what I can yeah
yeah the problem with that though is in
addition to wanting security you also
want variety and uniqueness right you
want an experience that is different
from everyone else's while also having
the security that everyone else has
right yeah yeah we want to drive a
hundred miles over the speed limit
without our seatbelt on but be okay and
the truth is yeah you you can drive fast
but you better have a you know a plan
you know you better have that seatbelt
in or in order to to survive
the reason I'm asking you what do you
want I think you want to get really
clear on on what you want but I think
you want to get even clearer on why you
want it and I'll just give you an
example from my own life
I I grew up really poor so you know just
we didn't have any money right
and growing up in that environment I
thought the answer to the reason we were
unhappy is because we didn't have money
and so when I turned 18 I went out and I
got that entry-level corporate job
thanks Jeff and I spent the next decade
twelve years climbing the corporate
ladder cuz I thought that's what I
wanted and it is what I wanted but I
didn't know why I wanted that I thought
I wanted a six-figure salary nothing
wrong with making six figures but I
didn't say why I wanted it was it so I
couldn't look like everyone else was it
so I could be secure or was it just
ostensibly secure and so get really
clear on what you want and even clearer
on why you want it and that will give
you the leverage to what make whatever
changes you need to make in your life
and and get on the same page with your
spouse you know the run in two separate
contests when you get in the boat
together and you start growing in the
same direction you go much faster so
really get in tune with what it is she
wants and why and then being able to
talk about yours that way I tell you
this we we need to learn to speak French
right and I know some of you think it
Chris ought to expand us what are you
talking about no I mean we need to speak
we if you're married like too many of us
say me or I I want or I want or I
deserve III that's the wrong spirit if
you're a family you're a team so it
needs to be we what I know we have
individual wants but what do we need for
the family what do we need to do to be
able to move forward and it's a uniting
force that helps you move forward that's
your question again
I Ryan do you know what time it is it is
time for the minimalists lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media so we're gonna get out our cell
phones right now oh yeah I'm just gonna
start tweeting no actually we usually
answer question of social media and if
you want to follow us there if you're
follow along at home
we're at the minimalists on social media
on Twitter and Facebook and Instagram
and reverie Jessica is she's somewhere
around here she's live tweeting the
event
ladies and gentlemen jessica lynn
williams wherever you are oh she's way
up there
princess Jessica she's the reason our
social media looks so beautiful and so
during the lightning round
Chris this is where Ryan and I usually
work hard over the course of a week to
craft a perfect tweetable answer but we
don't have a week and so what we'll do
is we'll just ramble on a bit and
eventually we'll have something that
someone can tweet hopefully Jess will
tweet it by the end so what we'll do
some money questions and then eventually
we'll get over to the side
howdy what's your name were you from
Quran right you come all the way out
here just to see us in Louisville yeah
[Laughter]
no sorry my question is weirdly
financial specific but maybe it'll help
other people I was wondering how you
felt about a 401 K versus a Roth IRA
because in my opinion it seems like the
Roth is more flexible so if an emergency
were to happen or something comes up in
your life where you suddenly need money
that you could take it out of the Roth
but I kind of see that as a negative
thing as well because kind of dangerous
playing with your retirement
those are both bad for emergencies the
answer is neither of those are good for
emergencies is it seriously I mean that
which is why you have the emergency fun
exactly right but going back to your
question the difference between the two
whenever you all hear Roth I want you to
start to get a tingly all right because
Roth means you use after-tax dollars
so all the money that happens all the
growth that happens happens tax-free the
government can't touch it again all
right so a Roth 401 K Roth IRA that's
all post tax dollars you've already paid
taxes on the money so now you're gonna
have tax-free growth that's the beauty
of that a 401 K is pre-tax meaning it's
taken out before you ever get your
paycheck so we have to pay taxes on our
401 K later when we start to take the
money out at age 59 and a half so here's
another thing with Roth IRAs you can
only put in $5,500 per year if you're
under the age of 50 but if you're over
the age of 50 you can do an extra
thousand so you could do 6500 but a 401
K you can hit at 24,000 so if I like to
say this
I love Roth I'd love to utilize Roth but
401 K also has a great place because it
allows you to put more money away so I
encourage people to utilize both start
with your 401 K again investing 15% of
your household income and then utilize
Roth IRA also but you may have an
opportunity on your job to do what's
called a Roth 401 K which again is a
great opportunity so both of those are
good for investing I would encourage 401
K first then Roth IRA but don't pull
money out for anything have an emergency
fund for that yeah I think that's the
the pithy answer from all of us here is
don't use your retirement to fund your
emergency yeah I I was I was admitting
all my financial mistakes of Chris
you're confessing I was confessing
because because of what I did in an
emergency situation so I got my first
tuition you know pay back I got that
first bill in the mail and I was very
very broke at the time and I was looking
at this bill this like you know
20-something thousand dollar almost
thirty thousand dollar bill and I'm like
how in the heck am I ever gonna pay this
off even making the payments was a bit
stressful
I bet the payments like two or three
bucks a month that was stressful so what
I did is I looked into my 401 K and I'm
like I have 45 thousand bucks in here I
could just use this to pay off my
student loan
I did but how much money you think I
gave up wit with a $35,000 401k it was
$15,000 off the top and you want to know
what it would be worth it I I do because
I want people to learn for my mistake
Chris I don't think you want to know
tell me I mean you look at that you know
you have almost a 50% reduction right
right off the right off the top then you
get hit with the taxes on the money that
you got and looking at that how much did
you tell me it was the five it was 30 it
was thirty five thousand thirty five
thousand was in there and how many years
ago was this this was back in 2012 2012
were in 2018 now so six years that forty
average rate you probably would be
hovering at close to around two hundred
two hundred twenty-five thousand dollars
well my god that hurts so bad
I take it back I did not want you to
tell me that I asked no you know what
though I mean it you know what though I
think this is a good example though
because you talk a lot about this how we
should not beat ourselves up over these
mistakes listen we have all made money
mistakes can we can I take a poll raise
your hand if you've ever done something
stupid with money okay welcome to the
human race we've all been there we've
all done it what we can't do though is
keep beating ourselves up right if you
if you do something once or twice we can
call it a mistake you start to do it
four or five times now it's not a
mistake it's called a choice so what we
have to do is start to make better
choices and we've got to let go of those
mistakes we can all be there and we've
done it let's just decide and choose to
be better
let's choose to move forward let go of
the past and that's how you grow forward
yeah man it reminds me of another
another football analogy you gave in
your book it's you know good players
they don't complain they make good plays
yeah yeah they don't make it why do you
keep bringing up football I love
football man I play ping pong in car did
you really know oh thank you thank you
we got three more questions in this line
then we'll get over to this one I
promise so we're gonna cut this one off
here we'll try to get through these
relatively quickly well we'll make it
the lightning around but oh yeah I
forgot we were in the way that's right
are you from I'm Ariel and I'm from New
Albany right across the river
quills is from I was gonna say so my
question has to do with my job
so February last year I had a nervous
breakdown and actually how I got through
it that day was watching your all's
documentary on repeat
I watched it probably six times that
first day and the muck that was the only
thing that calmed me down
wow this is the this is the best
compliment things seriously thank you so
much I'm so glad that we could do
something for you in such a hard time
that's why Josh this is why Josh and I
do it I mean I'm so glad that you all
are here but that's why we do it and and
the whole reason that happened was
something fell out of my fridge and I
couldn't get the fire stick to work my
house was so messy I've been a single
mom
like for six years and my job was really
bad and I just like I couldn't take
anything anymore so just there's just
crap everywhere all over the house and
then it's kind of like lost my crap
there but anyway so I took two weeks off
of work to kind of work things out I
started giving stuff away and started
downsizing and then I went back to work
and I lost my job so then I was had a
marketing job I was making a lot more
money than I realized I was making
because of how much I was spending and
then I found out I had no income I like
started just doing favors for people you
know mowing yards and power washing
doing all kinds of like crazy stuff to
make money Rob Lowe because I didn't
want to go back to serving because my
family makes me feel like it's less than
cuz I have a college degree I had a
grown-up job like finally like I was
like a good example for my daughter and
then going back to serving is just not
good enough so then I've spent this last
year doing serving and then I've got
another marketing job and I'm just
like every day I go to work I'm just
really unhappy and the place I work for
is wonderful but I just sit there and
I'm like I don't want to do this I don't
want to write Facebook posts for this
stupid building inspector and I didn't I
like being with people and I like doing
that stuff and I like my husband and I
we just got married last month and we
bought a graduation thanks but we bought
a house in October and so like we have
our kids we have our house we have all
that stuff and he plays in a band and we
do all these different things these
different side jobs where we make money
that we really enjoy doing but like this
job job I have just makes me miserable
and so we've talked about since we
started dating like hey let's make
t-shirts let's let's deejay weddings
let's do all this stuff like full-time
but my parents make me feel like garbage
because I have a college degree and I'm
not a stupid person huh how much debt do
you have nine why are you still there
well and now it's the thing like I had
all this savings like built up and then
when I lost my job I had to use my
savings to pay my bills but I still
don't have any debt the answer how
miserable are you willing to be to
impress the people around you talk to my
grandma you know but my pithy answer
would be other people's expectations
well they're just that it's their
expectations
do not let other people's expectations
ruin your life if your family loves you
if they truly love you then they want
you to be happy and if they want you to
be happy they will support you and the
people in your life who don't support
you and who don't want you to be happy
and they want you to live up to their
expectations I can care less about your
own you have to love those people from a
distance mm-hmm yeah I want you I mean
that's great
that's
I tell you this opinions are like
yesterday's everyone has them you get to
make choices for yourself and so I want
you to put up a guard around your heart
and you and your husband start to talk
about what's moving forward for you all
and I want you to let people know
information about what's going on but
don't accept their advice meaning they
don't get a vote if you don't have a
foot in that household where you and
your husband are they don't have a vote
anymore you can love them like you said
at a distance but don't let them don't
let them in your heart anymore have put
a guard around your inner circle and be
careful and you go live your life and
let them live theirs absolutely I you
know yeah I was just gonna say I don't
want you to think that we're coming
across as cool we're not telling you to
be cool towards your family have the
conversation with them hey mom hey
grandma you love me don't you
well of course I love you yeah I love
you too grams hey don't don't you want
me to be happy I know I that I want you
to be happy of course I want you to be
happy
grams you know what I really need some
support in order to be happy I need your
support and here's how I need it would
you be willing to give me support I mean
have that conversation first but
ultimately yes if you have that
conversation you've gone out of your way
to pour your heart out and ask for
support people aren't willing to support
you you do have to put up a little bit
of a guard so you and not just you but
your family can live a really really
happy meaningful life thank you thank
you for yourselves well
Kelly what your name were you from
actually like three weeks ago Chris a
couple of questions got that thick
Kentucky accent I've been working on it
you can move that mic up a little bit do
you consider a house lay ability or an
asset and for a guy who moves for his
job every two three years
is it really worth it or smart idea for
me to consider buying or just continue
renting every time I come close to the
idea some people change my mind no go
ahead and like just continue renting and
I've been doing this for quite some time
okay
great there's a lightning round so a
house so I consider it an asset or a
liability if you if you look at it homes
appreciate and if you're paying in an
attacking the debt I look at a home as
an asset okay if you're taking on a debt
and thirty-year mortgage and you're only
making the minimum payment is just
hanging around hanging around hanging
around then it's a potential liability
with you moving your job every two to
three years that's going to you buying a
home is gonna be a challenge so I would
say renting does not throw away money it
allows you to save up so you can buy a
home the right way someday so you would
have to really be careful renting to me
sounds like the best way to go otherwise
you could move a couple of times and
have two houses on the market that
haven't sold yeah to me cuz you are so
unsure right now I would say continue to
rent because right now you're paying for
the freedom to be able to walk away and
that is huge so but here's my pet the
answer is you absolutely should buy a
house if you can afford it and what that
means 20% down on a 10-year maybe
15-year loan if you can't do that then
you can't afford to buy a house and also
I think think to echo what Chris said
the cost associated with moving over a
few years and the closing cost probably
isn't gonna be worth it with if you're
moving every 2 or 3 years I know people
will tell you that you're throwing your
money away but it sounds to me that they
don't really understand the the buying
process then because you know there are
the believe it's it's two countries
where the standard there's 193 countries
in the world the standard is this
30-year mortgage right now of course
dozens of other countries have piled on
because they want their chunk of the so
called America
dream which is 30 years of debt and so
there are a lot of other countries now
that are offering these these 30 year
mortgages but I think that's not a route
you obviously want to take and here's
another thing when you get tired of all
that moving and you want to get stable
it might be time to look at another
career right start to see those options
that allow you to be still a little bit
longer and you're right renting is not
throwing away money it helps you save up
time guys do you know there are 40 year
mortgages out there now what is bargain
oh that makes me for eight and fifty
years start out on the west coast and
it's starting to move this direction
yeah in the next four to five years
we'll start to see them a lot more Wow I
mean it makes me think you've seen this
with cars now some of the car loans
where it's 85 months and you're like
wait a minute and of course you're
buying a car every few years when you're
doing those types of things as opposed
to owning a car I mean with a car you
know I would never want to go into debt
to own a the thing that takes me to work
so I can pay for the thing that takes me
to work it's a depreciating asset yes
that's right don't do it thanks so much
three question I want more lightning
round question and we have three more
questions over here will do for our
PostScript segment okay what's your name
where you from Carrie and I'm from San
Bernardino California and I flew in to
see you oh my goodness thank you thank
you so much my question to you Chris is
can you overdo baby steps four and six
we are putting in twenty percent my
husband and I enter our retirement fence
each plus we're doubling or tripling our
mortgage every month is there I don't
Wow okay so you all are very very
focused right and so to reiterate for
every one baby step number four is
investing and I still tell people 15%
okay and then baby step six is where
you're paying off the house right look
he's got a shirt that says not retired
inspired yet
I love it oh you won't vote oh you have
shirts with my initials on maybe they
didn't fly in to see you No
just don't say for them
[Applause]
say I'm just gonna put it out there why
do you think Josh but seriously yeah
can you overdo it making double and
triple mortgage payments you can and I
think you all are at a point where you
just need to talk and look and say hey
do we need to take some breathing room
right you all are moving in the right
direction and it might be that you all
need to take that trip and pay cash and
enjoy and have some fun
but yeah you can't get too intense and
the problem with that is you can end up
burning out or blowing out a tire later
and so let's drive the cards just like a
clutch let's know when to press the gas
and when to let off a little bit and you
all know each other enough how long have
you been married she looked to him
that's a long time y'all been married a
while almost 30 years congratulations
but that's why I'd say you all make
those decisions together and really
start to look and enjoy life you're
moving forward you're moving in the
right direction stay the course all
right yes thank you thank you for being
here alright Joe if you're listening to
this at home and you have a comment or a
tip or even a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine or
you could send a voice memo to podcast
at the minimalists com it's my favorite
part of the show at the very end we air
our listeners comments and tips and then
we promptly steal your answers and
re-appropriate them later so feel free
to listen to the end of this episode for
this week's comments and tips and then
we don't do any advertisements on this
podcast because advertisements well you
know Birmingham do that a little bit
better so let's try something different
here okay this podcast is brought to you
by nobody
because advertisements yeah most
advertisements kind of suck right and so
instead of doing advertisements for
another mattress or sleep system or
something what we've decided to do is be
a hundred percent listener-supported so
if you want to support us you can do so
over at the minimal
komm slash support that helps pay for
our podcast studio on los angeles and
each week we do a postscript episode for
all of our patreon supporters over there
and it shows up in your regular podcast
player and so let's go ahead and record
one of those PostScript episodes in
front of y'all if you're open to that
Shawn this would be an appropriate time
in the Edit to like insert the sample or
the the excerpt from this week's
PostScript episode if you do a good
enough job helping people solve problems
you'll stop worrying about money as well
because ultimately that's what that's
what good businesses do by the way
that's what I mean we often joke about
advertisement advertisement suck well
most marketing sucks too but marketing
when marketing is done correctly it
means here let me help you with
something right it's helping people
solve problems and I think some
advertisements out there very few but
there are some even some advertisements
that that present a product or a service
that help solve a problem for people the
problem with advertising now is we see
5,000 advertisements a day and you know
4,500 of them are such manipulative
nonsense that it makes it difficult for
the other 500 and that really
breakthrough and that are inspirational
the change people and Ryan and I don't
personally do advertisements on on what
we do but it doesn't mean that there
aren't some that will actually help some
people solve problems so I guess what
I'm saying here is that no matter what
you do if it's business or just as an
individual if you find a way to
continuously help people solve their
problems you're not trying to make money
but it will happen
[Music]
Podcast john i think that's a it's a
good place to end the postscript segment
and go back to our our regularly
scheduled podcast ladies and gentleman
podcast Shawn hiding in the shadows back
there somewhere Shawn is a minimalist
with many hats
he is our podcast producer he is our
road manager our tour manager our bus
driver our director of operations
look editor essay editor don't look very
minimalist with hats yeah Shawn we
really appreciate you thank you so much
and we'll move on to a segment I'm gonna
skip order I'm gonna reverse orders here
we have a segment called right here
right now where we talk about what's
going on in the lives of the minimalist
I already talked about this grocery
store we're trying to build on the west
side of Dayton if you're listening this
at home you can help out with that as
well I just turned 37 and I donated my
37th birthday instead of getting me
another tie clip that I don't need or
some cufflinks I figure some folks could
donate 37 dollars on my birthday and if
you want to give me that gift I'd really
appreciate it cuz you can help feed some
families provide food to people who
don't have access to good food I mean
you can go to West Dayton right now and
you can buy food you can get cheetos at
the local at the local liquor store
burritos yeah you're the one that said
it earlier man but you can't get
nutrition there on the west side and we
want to help change that by providing
good food quality food for people who
need it if you want help out just go to
the minimalists comm slash dayton a
hundred percent of the profits from
tonight are gonna go to that as well so
thank you all for being a part of that
[Applause]
also speaking of what's going on the
lives of the minimalist we are putting
on our second documentary with Matt Thea
Vela that should be out later this year
but we're also focusing on a lot more
short form meaningful video creations
and so we have a new team member and
he's here with us tonight ladies and
gentlemen
Jordan Moore is here on the camera we
decided we need we needed a filmmaker to
help us create more meaningful things so
video essay is obviously the if you're
watching this on YouTube right now we
have a video version of the podcast we
just started so you can find that at the
minimalists comm slash YouTube and you
can find a bunch of other stuff we're
gonna do a bunch of different shows
short form stuff including we said Chris
on living room conversations we do this
little weekly thing now called living
room conversations you can check out
there on YouTube or let's move on to the
added value segment of the show so we
talked about some things that have added
value to our lives
recently Ryan what has added value to
your life recently we talked about
quills earlier if you haven't been there
good of quills it's awesome coughing um
I got two more things every dollar app
for whoo all right actually I won't make
you raise your hand but there's other
people besides that gentleman who does
not have a budget right now and I would
HIGHLY encourage you get it but if you
got money problems the first thing you
start with is a budget I mean when my
mentoring students come in to me and
they're like oh man I'm in this heap of
dead and and I don't know where my
money's going and and I need you to help
me kind of you know fix this situation
I'm in we might be 10 minutes into the
call and I'll say hey look you need to
come up with a budget this is step
number one to getting out of money
problems after you have your budget then
let's talk more about your money
problems so there's an awesome app
called every dollar that I use it's it's
it's it's a great great app that lets
you keep track of every single dollar a
dollar that you have your set your but
your budget at the beginning of the
month and then every single purchase you
go in that app and you put your expenses
in there and it is powerful when you do
that
the only thing I'm gonna recommend
because Chris is here with us is retired
inspired it's it's a wonderful
book on how to retire they know there
are they're like I I'm so impressed with
what you all are doing that is amazing
that what you're able to save and then
pay off towards your mortgage that is
that is incredible keep that up but what
I really appreciate but appreciate about
your book the most Chris is that you
could be twenty years old you could be
six years old or anywhere in between and
you've got a device for people on how
they can live their life live a good
retired life they really can I mean they
have the opportunity to make the
decision so it's never too early to get
started and it's absolutely not too late
I don't care what you hear out there or
in the news it's not too late trust me
I'm seeing people get started and turn
things around Chris I just want to
acknowledge you I think you're doing
something special for the world you're
certainly adding value to a lot of
people's lives I know you've got a new
book coming out by the time this episode
comes out if you're listening to this at
home you can pre-order your new book
it's called everyday millionaires and
it's gonna show people that you know
what your average teacher your average
nurse your average accountant these are
the types of people who are everyday
millionaires it's not some guy in an
ivory tower laughing down at the minions
I mean there are a few of those too I'm
sure but they're not the everyday
millionaires right no it's available
people can people can get started and
help themselves and we're gonna chop
down myths in the book I'm gonna talk
about the attributes of what
millionaires look like I'm gonna talk
about the giving that they're able to do
you know the impact they can have on the
world but again it's taken some steps
helping people have to plan and also the
research restarted over 10,000 of them
and so we're gonna really unpack that
and help people to see the truth I just
imagine Chris in like a white lab coat
and he's got this room like he's a
double-sided mirror and he's looking at
a bunch of millionaires he's got his
clipboard going I'm pretty sure that's
how happened right it's exactly went
down it was not a little lamp goes
I'm a big man man years of ping-pong so
everything that we talked about today
podcast Shawn will put in the show notes
including links to to Chris's book also
his podcast which is also called retired
inspired and one other thing that's been
adding value to our life recently so
we're doing this little three-city tour
and we had this gentleman named Paul you
might know him as Canyon City open up
the show earlier would you think of that
[Applause]
what I'll tell you what I discovered his
albums he has a couple albums I
discovered one of them last year his
newest one called constellation and it
came out I like to invite him back up on
stage right now when the album came out
I I found it in like Ryan you and I were
just talking about this backstage how
it's amazing like I just admire him I
think he's one of the best songwriters
out there and and whenever I listened I
turned that album on it just sounds like
home to me in a way that it's hard for
me to explain and so instead of me
trying to explain music to you how about
we have Canyon City play the first song
from that album it's called our way
[Applause]
thank you so much really all three of
you I mean it just it's I don't know
about you guys but I I lose my way from
time to time and to be able to just hear
what these guys have to say and glean
some of that wisdom it really adds so
much value to my life and it's just I
feel like I'm getting a steal getting to
follow these guys around and since in
these conversations so thanks to them
thanks to you guys for for making this
such a special night
so anyway so song all about being
mid-journey
and I'm learning that that just kind of
means that you're alive that you're
still that you're still breathing you're
still here and to have a little less
aversion to it
and my voice is not going to sound
nearly as good as Chris's so just lower
the bar we'll do our best
[Music]
clear I'll be learning clown show pirate
ship tried in the win
when the flow comes rise to know art
Oh clear I be when I thought
[Music]
look at my face times drawing a line a
crossed I lost with her own divides
but I think I'm gonna going tonight oh I
still don't know but Oh
[Music]
maybe if we don't know where we go with
Roland's
Burrell and it feels like home
oh babe you'll never say that we lost
our way
oh we lost our way
[Music]
do you think it is time
it's stick in the ground
[Music]
if you come
we're fine
[Music]
they're digging now I think I'll try
Oh
[Music]
maybe if we don't know where we go with
Roland's relay the fuse like obeyed
they'll never say if we lost our way
oh we lost our way
[Music]
ranges con taking the crowd starts its
shaking thank God for the break into
because though I hate how it feels
I love hearty it brings me back to you
maybe if we don't know where we go with
these these land everything that feels
like home
oh babe he'll never say the wheel our
stowaway
[Music]
if a they can't ever see the wheel our
star
[Music]
gotta gives me chills man Wow whenever
whenever I go back to Ohio I just sort
of put that album on and drive around a
bit and there's just something there's
something about the words that I can't
describe and that's why I wanted in the
bi here tonight
Paul thank you so much check out Canyon
City wherever you check out music thank
you so much all right before we wrap up
let's thank the mercury ballroom for
Avila is here tonight what a great spot
right who knew we could cram this many
Kentuckians in one place and we're
grateful for that I'm grateful for this
Kentucky and especially thank you so
much for a 2-page your thank you man
I'll give you a hug thank you thank you
all right Joe if you leave here tonight
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works that's your time
yeah thanks Louisville
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello this is Anna originally from Spain
but calling from Amsterdam the
Netherlands so I have a few tips that I
would like to share that came into my
mind once I listened to the podcast on
anxiety and my first two tips are
related to breathing techniques and I
have been using this breathing technique
called
four seven eight for a few years now I
it is very short and easy to do it takes
less than two minutes and I tend to do
it twice a day right before I go to bed
so I wind down and get ready to have a
good night's sleep and also first thing
in the morning when I wake up so if you
type on Google breathing technique for
seven eight you will find plenty of
links and resources there are even some
YouTube videos explaining how to do this
technique still let's say you're not
very convinced that's why this technique
or any breathing technique would help I
would strongly recommend that you check
one of the TED talks videos called
breathe to heal by Max Strom and this
video definitely pushed me into trying
some of these breathing techniques and
in the video the speaker explains how
breathing techniques have helped
enormously people with post-traumatic
syndromes and motor tip that I have has
to do with people who struggle managing
their priorities their goals their daily
life and that Karen's a UT because teens
start to pile up and I recently came
across this book called
time surfing the Sun approach to keeping
time on your side written by Paul lumens
and this is a Dutch author
the book has been written and translated
into English and I have checked and you
can purchase it as well in the US of
course in Europe too and this is a book
that I really enjoy because it's it
gives you like a seven step approach on
how to handle your time but instead of
trying to control it and that's why the
book is called time surfing just mostly
refocus on the aspect of how to navigate
difficulties from a Buddhist or Zen
approach and it really does not an
inductor innate people into converting
into Buddhism or anything like that is
very very simple and I don't always
apply all the steps but I keep coming
back and forward to one of two some of
these advices that you can find on the
book and they have also added a lot of
value to my life hi guys I'm Christina
and I'm a bit older than those who
called in about their relationships with
their parents here's my advice you ask
if you can forgive them for their
imperfections I hope so and I hope they
forgive you years unless your parents
were abusive they probably loved you and
did the best they could my parents
weren't perfect but I wasn't a perfect
daughter either there were years I'm
sure where I was a pain in the ass
unkind and insensitive to their feelings
parents have shortcomings but they also
have feelings
children have shortcomings and feelings
it's an imperfect world and we're all
imperfect it took me a while to realize
that my parents did the best they could
years probably did too my parents were
raised in unfortunate circumstances
extreme poverty alcoholism other bad
things and yet they were raised in
better circumstances than their parents
who grew up an even worse poverty and
deprivation in Europe everyone does the
best they can dear parents scorned your
lifestyle as a minimalist maybe but you
are probably scouring their lifestyle
too my parents were raised during the
Great Depression and they held on to
everything and yes I got to clear it all
out during their later years and after
their death it was not fun in fact it
was agonizing but that's life people
have their own values and beliefs my
parents had a terror
poverty and while I might see that
saving 100 plastic yogurt containers
expired bottles of aspirin or worn-out
towels will not help avoid poverty they
didn't see it that way I inherited their
frugality which was a good thing they
didn't believe in debt and that belief
has served me well and I have let go
after much angst sometimes of their
other beliefs beliefs that it's wasteful
to ever get rid of anything that divorce
is a sin that life is fraught with peril
and we should be vigilant and fearful at
all times I let go of those and when
they rear their heads I look at them and
let go again your parents are just
people with their own failings you learn
some good things from them and use those
lessons and the other stuff work hard to
let it go and if you have to clear out
their garages and storage lockers after
they die you as a minimalist will be
well equipped to do it hi this is Xena
calling from the Chou Islands in the UK
I just wanted to give some advice to
anyone who might be planning their
wedding I'm currently in the stages of
planning ours and as you probably know
it can get expensive very quickly so
we're looking at different ways that we
can reduce the costs and we were
discussing our wedding rings and
basically I have some old jewelry that I
no longer wear and I was looking at how
I could let these go so an idea that we
had was to trade in this old jewelry I
no longer wear to reduce the cost of the
wedding rings and we managed to reduce
it right about 20 pounds by trading in
this old jewelry which I know it doesn't
sound like a lot in the grand scheme of
things but every little helps
and it was a really nice way of letting
go of some old jewelry and putting the
money towards something meaningful
towards our future and minimus